faire changer ton look way ainsi qu'en
mer j'ai mes chevaux les cheveux oui et
puis les compliquer côtelettes l'aller
ou flac est la plus forte en poule beau
tatoué sur l'épaule
bah oui c'est pour toujours ouais tu
regrettes pas des joueurs quand tu
prends ta douche de voir ça sur les
bruits non non tout content âgées pas
que ça en plus t'as quoi et un aigle
j'ai une gonzesse
c'est un petit commente de marib à mal
le litas et elle elle et dominique se
défait de la lecture et affable alors
alors tuer tuer a dit en fait que tu as
changé ton look parce que tu voyais des
renault par tous c'est à dire que je
suis dit par exemple que tu avais un
foulard rouge autour du cou
tu la mettais au poignet quinze jours
après au premier rang il avait 15 mai
qu'elle faisait full house je trouvais
voir c'est ça ouais donc c'est pas faux
que pour ça non mais ça existe un peu
agaçant ce phénomène d'identification
contre les mecs pour trouver qui tu es
mais ils s'habillaient comme toi c'est
vraiment moi même j'étais une caricature
où je sais pas si c'était eux au moins
soit 20 mai que vous voyez dans la rue
régale de l'habiller comme renault
les états non j'ai donné du mal pour
être star maintenant que tu es start a
l'air de vivre assez mal de célébrité 90
je sais pas tu dis quand je vais au
megastore par exemple je garde mon
casque de moto le plus longtemps
possible sur la plage est fait pour vous
et je la dis cela mais j'aime pas il
devrait en république et le quart de
tour j'ai dit je serai plus à l'aise
finalement si je chantais à l'abri des
oreilles un peu comme ça je serais plus
plus tranquille quoi l abri des bravo
voilà bruit de l'argent et des oreilles
le journaliste qui posait des questions
avait dit ce mot gêne pas de chanter
puis que vous dites deviennent des vos
chansons deviennent d un produit vous
même vous soyez pour une consommation
élevée de consommation que celle de nêne
fasse partie de l'industrie comme du
capitalisme tout ça je suis dit que
peut-être quelque part au fond mon
subconscient
j'aurais préféré vivre dans un pays
totalitaire et chanter des chansons dans
à l'ombre d'une cave à l'abri des
oreilles de la milice de la milice qu
elle apparaître un prologue comme si le
pen est hélas tu vivrais d'entre eux
pourraient planquer pour chanter alors